when an artist can dance that makes them
a thousand times better than anyone else
what's my dance experience like zero I
will say that I watched music videos and
be like that looks easy
I chose iconic music video choreography
not dance crazes to show you just how
difficult your favorite artists dance
moves actually are how do you dance the
Thriller when you hear it you have to
learn down thrust and for coming really
thrust you've got a really dressed are
you not wearing shoes I need shoes for
this oh god you guys gonna be the worst
as a child of the 80s this is like
muscle memory it's hard to be a sexy
zombie because thumbies feel so dead
Michael Jackson was a sexy song I know
I'm gonna do without you is that the
thing yeah I feel like with all these
dances we're gonna see something that
caught on that's like slightly
complicated it's not super easy there's
a reason why he was the greatest
entertainer of our generation the part
that it's easy for everyone else to do
is the only part you remember that was
terrible he's pretty perfect what do you
think voguing looks like [ __ ]
already unnatural everything's always at
a very sharp angle all that hurts
Vogons both powerful but elegant very
smooth but also super control new
twitter and all of those things but ah
yes you're delivering arms and fix yes
nope that's yeah that's not happening
because it's sexy in a different way
it's like power sexy
I feel empowered the power Madonna it's
hard to keep it all internal and like
keep a blank stare because you're doing
so much working it's like how are you
not breathing very hard it'd be super
easy to like improv it but choreograph
with other people about this are they do
vote oh yes vote battle
I've got the Timberlake bandana right
now I know the part of it is this right
yeah if you're lazy instinct is very
explosive give it more swagger yeah stop
being such a white boy no one seems to
do this move quite right I'm over here
like ya left the bed what it's like this
is 95 yeah I told you I was a horrible
dancer I'm a look at these but it's okay
I'm not
100% attitude that would have helped me
my social life why should you do it one
more time yeah that was a lot of fun I
guess you just don't think about how
physical it can be it's kind of sad that
most of today's boy bands to dance like
this anymore I feel like I've learned it
one way so long that I thought this was
the right way but it's really this and
now when I try to correct it I'm like
five second side my wife and I went to a
Britney Spears concert in Las Vegas
oops Ned mentioned his wife again it's
already too much I'm looks like you're
throwing a ball back at a baseball game
Chris your shimmy it's not that it's
this why is she walking like it's chic a
lot of this routine is actually in
fourth position
does anyone have ballet experience here
that's how you do it yeah I never knew
how she did it yeah I thought the old
lady threw it in the ocean
I feel like you've seen instead it again
a billion times growing up so it's just
a little bit easier to walk into my mind
I feel like I've been sixth grade again
and I'm just dancing my friends I
literally got lost in this game the
movements mimic the lyrics maybe doesn't
look easy in the nude video but I
certainly didn't think it was this hard
Britney makes it look so easy though I
feel like 2007 Britney huh janitor sit
the one where her boob pops out during
the Super Bowl no okay cuz I can do that
one Rhythm Nation
oh this videos intense you guys three
these two fingers damn well we're not
gonna flip it off so she wasn't that
dystopian though I bet this happened
really fast
the reason many people can't do it Jaina
dances because they are so damn hard
she is really complex dances make your
face hard make your face hard tack the
actual tempo is fight someone with that
it's so fast and precise that it's gonna
be done by the time you realize I'm
[ __ ] it up this one's for you baby
it was incredibly fast and technical I
just know people are in classes for most
tour and her stuff yeah this is high but
it's fun it felt like a military music
piece I just wanna apologize to miss
Jackson if she ever sees this
what is Beyonce's most famous
choreographed we're gonna be Beyonce I
can't do it oh I already read II to
catch me I might fall on you wait there
are armed - this is the hardest dance
we've done and that's it the hand roll
to the left
No
sitting me you know all of these dances
you think are so easy and then the
little I'm so impressed it's incredibly
difficult
I can't imagine singing and doing this
at the same time to do it in heels I
have so much more respect for not only
women in general but women performers
particularly look sexy as hell music
video and we look like like we had too
much to drink at book club here a bunch
of Michelle's in a world that belongs to
Beyonce it's a little girl dancing so
she can do it will have no problem yeah
she's like she's a professional dancer
who has crazy acrobatic skills we're
gonna do one of the simpler parts oh
it's good it's the stuff of the table I
love this part and seven and punch whoa
and your head slams on the table [ __ ]
not gonna be able to do it I'm too tall
this dance is not made for people with
glasses pull your own head up this is
dope and your face is going like mmm and
you grab it Wow and you throw it away
you go Willy moon and you're gonna be a
tiger York I'm pregnant he could be
making this up as he went on this is
important don't punch me in the face
that was the most fun it just came from
a motion we were attaching it to things
instead of numbers it's sort of like
speaking there's a bunch of different
ways you can say something but it still
is the same message it takes time and
work till I get her just like any art we
were definitely like the best group at
BuzzFeed at dancing right god damn job
you know dance look sexy also girls
learn to code that's quicker